Kunol, we missed you in
the last interview with Krohl.
>> I know, I should have been there.
I'll do the next one for sure.
>> Okay.
But you know what?
>> What?
>> We finished lesson one.
>> No.
>> Yeah, we're done.
>> You're telling me we're one-third
of the way through the course?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, that's great.
>> And you know what we should do now?
No.
>> We should recap.
>> We should.
>> So the first part of the lesson
we learn about how a screen
is made of different views.
>> Yep, image view and text view.
>> And
we learned how to style those views.
>> So if you want to change
the color of a text for instance.
And in the final bit,
what we did was took different views and
put them together.
So we call them view groups.
We use linear layout, relative layout,
we use margin and padding.
Yup, so we're done now.
>> And that's Lesson 1.
All right.
[SOUND]
>> Nice.
>> I got a chilled raspberry
fruit loop tea for
Kunol, and green tea for Catherine.
You know, they haven't even really
talked about Android Studio.
Let's fix that.